so this is something you sent to chin
and i to bring up
um there is a tick tucker who is balding
and he likes to wear the equivalent of
today's toupee here we go he likes it
here we go
don't say this stuff having a hairpin
thinks it promotes
confidence in men who are balding scroll
down this kid look at that kid's balding
no look at him
wow he looks like he's like 20 something
he's balding
that's like his hair now look that that
him that's terrible that could be you
brian nope
it's not gonna be me you're not gonna do
a little hairpiece no look at that dude
no that's a little kid a toupee oh
that's a little
legit does that look though dude yeah
look that's basically just here look at
that
that one's pretty good would you do that
brian sure with the philly phase i'll do
it for
this [ __ ] podcast i think you should
do it but i don't i don't really
appreciate how much i think i need that
right now
you know you need that i look good from
this angle
dude your hair's getting thinner by the
month it is i gotta get back on the on
my hems
that's no it's that's too late you
should how much is this
chin hundred nine hundred like this it
probably depends on where you go
because like the cost oh you can get it
anywhere cost different the person
installing it i think they got i think
they glue it on
and it's never happening and he's blown
up like he was only doing two or three
but since he went viral on tick tock now
he's doing a bunch dude
the guy that actually that's the
earplugs range from four thousand
fifteen thousand
i'll go get those again and see if they
work the second time
no a hair piece can go with the stick
tiger gotcha
i don't know man i'm not doing that and
i don't really which i said so scroll
down
it says the hair piece can go without a
touch-up for just four to six months
that's hilarious and it just it's it's
it's probably glued to your head how do
they do it keep scrolling down
oh sales at pr it's in la increased 30
percent
you shut up we're doing upwards of 10 to
16 replace the maintenance
appointment a big increase from five to
six i'm not doing it you're right
you're questioning 950 bucks dude i'm
not what if we sponsor it
you can go [ __ ] off i'm not gonna go get
my [ __ ] hair shaved
my head shave and then they glue that on
me no you keep what you have we're just
gonna glue it on top
no no they gotta cut that so i gotta
wear that
i wear a [ __ ] hat they gotta cut
they've gotta cut more than a hat
you gotta [ __ ] off them now can you do
it the next time you get bored and
cut your hair yes and buzz it up i might
shave my head do you wear hats
no i don't look so good in hats okay see
one of those gay like beach heads if i
wear them backwards
all right and if i want to keep this oh
you got a bucket playing tennis i wear
that bucket hat
yeah you got a bucket oh no i don't play
like that though
don't do the mad hat no don't do that i
come over the ball like that but look at
this guy dude that's what i'm saying
i saw this i'm like [ __ ] this would be
so good for kevin you can go [ __ ] off
all right
because i don't appreciate that look at
him though he's young that's the tough
part too because well he should just
shave
the sides no but you can't because
that's how you do the fade so you have
to cut your hair like you're balding
right on top
oh and put it on top and then fade it up
yeah well i think they cut his hair that
way you have to be this way
let me see the after channel there's
people are not going to run before you
yeah who's going to pull your hair first
of all you [ __ ]
i'm not doing it unreal i thought this
was like a light you need you said you
you just said you do it for the podcast
they can clone hair when that happens
you're me dead
i'm the first no i won't they they might
be able to clone here in about five six
years
60 something well whatever i am dude we
don't have to get in my age whatever
i'm gonna look good though you won't
even consider this 950 bucks
no i won't i'm not wearing i'm not too
pay guy dude
that's not a toupee this is different
you know when you're getting older
the last thing you want to do is dumb
[ __ ] like that i already got my lips you
did your eyes
i did this guy's in his 20s that was
because my mom told me that
that i it was it was just looking your
mom didn't impress you then i got it
that's all you dude
no my mom said you should get it either
your mom or your girl
no it's my mom she got it done and she
said in our family we get these heavy
lids and i was getting it
and it looked stupid and she goes and
it'll get it in the way of your eyesight
do it now when nobody notices
so i did it and this is an easier
process than that in the lid if you're
going to do the lids the little
younger lids that were painless but it
was a bit of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah i was awesome it was awful
it was so bad i technically had two
plastic surgery operations
one on my head on one of my eyes yeah
that you don't have people for getting
plastic surgery and i thought
the other day i was like well i've had
two procedures major procedures on my
head eyes and the
the slice them back yeah now they take
just pieces that's what i'm saying
there's no there's no
transplant didn't take oh god
oh god that is awful this was one of
those
oh god i look great there don't i
look you're right look at my face
jesus christ holy moly
i had to get laser treated hollywood
because the blood was pulled there
um that's what i was gonna ask yeah
that's a tough look huh look at my look
like a bug look at my egg head i used to
be
cute as you get older your face starts
to do weird [ __ ] with gravity man
i was a cute kid i looked at pictures
when i was younger and i was i was all
right
you look good right great brian you look
great right now
dude don't don't bother me i just think
you i think you i'm looking
i just think uh that two-page stuff
would [ __ ] take your next level
no surgery no surgery you've already
done the eyes you're
you're so hollywood you've already done
the eyes you already have the huge scar
down the back here look
at me right now i'm not afraid of you
and i'll come at you
come at me with toupee though
i can do it i actually i know exactly
how corey saint hanging does that mean
perfect and i want you to do that with a
wiggler
i'll do that with my guy all right even
if i pay for it
even if you pay for it 150 dollars in a
[ __ ]
hat didn't your mom having a hot glue
did your
hair do it yeah she did i'm not having a
haircut around the eyes i don't listen
to her
i listen to her on the eyes she's saying
no because i'm a little vain
but i'm not wearing a hair hat for six
months because you think it'd be nifty
daddy's already done two cosmetic
surgery
that's where we have to draw the line
and this ain't a surgery this is [ __ ]
whoop
no i'm not doing any of that [ __ ] all
right i tried i wouldn't mind getting my
face like uh like peeled